please welcome princess Olga no yes so I
always wondered how to greet the
princess your your mother she was she
was not a part of this our family she
was actually Swedish or Finnish Scottish
Scottish surname MacDougall but with a
Swedish finished mother
I see so did you ever speak Swedish - do
you understand when we talk no I I can
understand a little I could never say it
but my mother when she reprimanded me
which was quite often when I was a child
would say words in Swedish which I knew
damn well what she was saying but I
would look completely blank until to say
yeah she had certain words when I sat in
elegantly with my legs apart you know
she'd say open windows but something
very very harsh understand tell me tell
me about how I mean this is the
centennial for the Russian Revolution
and your your grandmother was the sister
of the tsar nicolai ii correct yeah
thank you um she escaped thus our family
did not yeah that she is getting what
happened my grandmother my
great-grandmother and my father his
first wife and some of his and his
brothers his sister as well was married
to Felix Yusupov they all wearing a
house arrest in the Crimea eventually
the mole bruh HMS Marlborough is sent
over by George v to pick them up so
so the king of England he sent yes
they said it said the battleship to pick
them up but why did the Brits pick them
up so because my grandmother and Nikolas
her brother were first cousins to um
George v my great grandmother Empress of
Russia and her sister was the Queen of
England
so how when when your father and his
mother of the the rest of them arrived
here in England yeah Ali how were they
treated by the rest of the British l1
really they knew them very well and then
they'd often came for holidays here and
they were all together and they were all
together in Denmark because my
great-grandmother was a dame and when
you were born you had the Norwegian King
King Haakon was my godfather he was a
godfather yeah I had ten godparents and
he was one of them and he gave me he
gave me a brooch with the H and the
crown above but the jewels I was given
as a baby were for a baby
anyhow it's gone a long time ago I mean
I was a child
yeah you didn't sell it no no you were I
mean you you were a princess you are a
princess yeah you grew up as a princess
what kind of hole was that what kind of
home this did you have all sort of
English aristocracy socratic home the
usual type of things except everything
was very eccentric because I never went
to school you never went to school you
know why was that because my mother who
had had Hell except that the equivalent
of a Tom mother was born in 1908 the PAR
was born in 1897
my father was 54 when he had me my
mother was 42 own a child from that
Union he had three children who were
already in their 30s when I was born she
thought that she would give me a better
childhood at home with teachers and
tutors because she'd had hell from the
age of 8 at the equivalent of Tom Browns
school days some were on the coast the
south coast of England all the hell
when the south coast of England s and it
was really bad and she had a terrible
time so she thought she was doing me a
huge favor it used to say to her mom
it's a bloody good thing I'm not a boy
because I'd have been so gay it's not
true when this son was born speaking of
friends that must have been so lonely
then my friends were farm children and
was fine until my friends that went to
the local primary schools went to their
boarding schools which was Bennett and
lil Stern and bed spray the age of 12
then it would became difficult when I
realized this was odd because I always
imagined people that didn't go to school
would turn out really weird
[Applause]
what about servants did you have
servants not exactly when I was a child
we had quite a lot mrs. Benn when I was
first born there was a a nanny and under
nanny and a nursery maid though that was
in these are things that didn't happen
since that's all the First World War II
eight years before the First World War
said it had all those people and there
were agar two gardeners and a chauffeur
but then by the time I got to probably
five or six there was only one nanny
no no nursery maid and only to say that
sort of thing they're not really and
unto living living maids and the garden
ok time in 1968 was all gone it was all
done well yes except for a gardener
mother didn't like live-in staff because
you always have to behave rather well in
front of them I was thinking how this is
gonna go down no socialist Norway and
Sweden
I mean your mother sounds even more
royal than your father oh yeah she was
but she wasn't that understand she was
you know she had that persona of royalty
she is stingy but even went by even
before she married my father when she
was playing Miss mcdougal there was a
lot of she was know you everybody knew
who she was and what she was and how she
was the one she was Gemini does that
make a difference you know twins oh I
see yeah okay so on the one hand she was
just wonderful most amusing most warm
fantastic person on the other you could
be talking to her and mid-sentence the
eyes that was very pale blue the
Hyland's thing sort of fake would change
to ice blue and you knew you'd said
something wrong as you spoke I'm also a
Gemini can you sense that with me
[Music]
[Applause]
what she would you characterize her as a
little snobbish
she was pretty snobbish yes but nobody
else when I say these things sort of
realize how snobbish she was she had a
she had an aim for her one and only
daughter one of the only child which was
a brilliant marriage and I was
determined to prove her wrong there was
song I mean there was a newspaper
article about you being a possible wife
or the next Queen of England like when
Charles was like a young but that was a
1967 and at the same time each week they
did another foreign princess even the
speculation was some media or mother
happy I did it did and she put she put
it they know the virtues of the child
she didn't want to say horses because
that was the only thing I was interested
in so she put tennis I couldn't hit a
ball to save my life
challenges she did she was she wrote the
article I mean I know that she wrote the
article yeah they they asked her her
opinion of the widget would I like would
she like me to go into Harper's of
course and so she told them what to say
and one of my attributes was sculling
now I said what the hell but not in such
a fight this is the boat I've got a clue
what it meant I said I never even
something about I'm trying to fill me
and I'd make the sound more that's a
weird way of setting you though
do do the Romano family do they keep in
touch we quite a lot of us keep in touch
where on earth we have a pay or
messenger and every you have a chat
yeah ten of us ten of us say bonjour
Renault well good morning or whatever in
the morning and we'll say you know ciao
seat well in the evening it's a very
productive conversation all of you here
in Italy three initially one in Denmark
a lot in the States
another my sister-in-law's here that's
our family used to be very very wealthy
are you a wealthy family god I wish was
the sculling they'd had wealth in Russia
they were one of the richest families
but it wouldn't after the Revolution it
was obviously confiscated and they
didn't get out enough stuff to be able
to you know there had no money out of
Russia nothing he's got some amazing
sort of heirlooms though certain things
that are just from that era yeah and I
still got some but I had to sell a lot
to be able to do the matching finance of
English irritates right yeah yeah I know
you've been to Russia a few times indeed
um a couple of times to to actually
berry to give to give thus our family a
proper burial
tell me about that yeah the first time I
went in 98 and I ate 1998 with my one of
my sons and we were reburied Nikolas and
his family are two children with who was
still not buried and it was huge with 56
Romanoff's in luxury coaches mainly
staying at the Astoria and without
riders of the coaches and going through
red lights out of school and
we we met the Cotten's of the airport
and we heard that they lay in state for
a night and then we had a huge funeral
the next day and in Yeltsin told us the
day before he was coming so what's your
role on these occasions well what do you
do you know just stand up straight look
look alright and smile oh it's it's
fantastic to have you on the show
we're gonna have another guest on but
thank you so much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe